just over two weeks ago until the
midterms Democrats trying not only to
change the subject but to get convince
voters that they are the ones who are
tough on crime New York Governor Kathy
Hoka will be adding more police to the
city's subway system after a series of
shocking attacks the latest shows a man
shoved onto the tracks in an unprovoked
incident but critics argue her crime
pivot is purely political because she's
in a very tight race and New York City's
mayor might not be helping her case with
comments like this
I think that you you you were right
about you know not having your iPods in
not focusing on foam and I say yes to
that I do the same and we put out a a
video and information telling people
about being aware of what's around them
and what's taking place I encourage New
Yorkers to do that and blue State Oregon
could flip thanks to concerns over
Public Safety so it might not be an
accident that Portland's mayor now wants
a ban on homeless encampments
the homeless crisis in our city is
nothing short of a humanitarian
catastrophe we can better connect
homeless portlanders to State and County
Services by consolidating those critical
services in a number of large-scale
sanctioned sites
this will be paired with a phasing in of
a city-wide ban on self-cited
unsanctioned encampments
so that the the Mayors the governor's
race is very very tight and it looks
like the Republican could win because
Greg this experiment that they've had
has not worked he called it a
humanitarian catastrophe yeah in his own
City yeah now I can't believe this guy's
still around Portland's been a hell hole
since he's been there now mayor Adams he
does have a point to always be aware but
you have to now you're in a state where
you can't sit in the subway and play
candy crush anymore that that those days
are gone you have to look without
looking used to be you couldn't look in
people's eyes Now you kind of got to
look around the whole time and then
people they keep talking about this
pushing thing as as unprovoked or random
it's starting to look pretty deliberate
to Me Maybe random for the victim but it
seems deliberate it seems like when so
like that guy who did that that was
deliberate it almost makes me feel like
there's some kind of weird challenge
going on in the city that we weren't
told about and that because it's like
this is happening people just randomly
push people
the strangest and worst thing about this
and we keep talking about this is that
nothing gets done even though everybody
agrees it's horrible nothing gets done
so on one side we'll say it's the dem's
fault liberal Mayors on the other side
they'll say but it's Republican
governors in those States and then
there's no second act right it's like
okay well I'm happy to never blame
another Democrat no I will never blame
another Democrat to go that far if they
would just join and act fire Alvin Bragg
right get rid of no cash fail I will
forgive them for dragging their feet
over this and waiting for politics
political consequences just do it one of
the things that they said they're going
to do judge is ADD 1200 cops to the
subway system this is the just announced
on on Friday into Saturday and that's
going to be in overtime because there's
not enough cops well that's the whole
point over time how how long can these
cops work before they're exhausted I
mean you know that's great and by the
way you figure this out uh a local two
weeks before the election and by the way
I don't forget give them for not doing
this earlier do you know how many people
have been killed assaulted raped or the
the guy pushed off the train it was
suicidal his mother says he's suicidal
push off the platform but he wasn't hit
thank God and you know what for Adams to
say you know you got to be aware no
kidding Dick Tracy why don't you do
something about it I am so tired of
going after this bear but he doesn't do
anything about it it's it's a it's a
fault of Albany cashless bail can be
resolved and that's why Lee zeldon said
when I become governor I'm going to
replace Alvin Bragg as the mayor of the
D.A of Manhattan and I'm going to make
sure that we pass a bill that revokes
the cashless fail this is you don't need
to be a genius to figure this out and
the fact that these Democrats like this
guy wheeler I remember him from the
summer of 2020. now all of a sudden he
says this is a vortex of of insanity he
only is offering three camps for three
thousand people the camps hold 125 each
these people this is theater to them
it's about power they come out at the
last minute so that they can get
reelected and get their power they don't
care about us They Don't Care About
victims and this mayor of New York City
as far as I'm concerned he doesn't care
about victims because he's not fighting
for the victims Jesse one of the things
that this mayor in Portland is realizing
is something that other cities have
figured out and thankfully New York
doesn't have which is you can't allow
tents on the sidewalk encampments are
not a good idea camping's for the woods
it's not for the city this guy they
defunded the police and then crime
exploited they decriminalized drugs and
homelessness and overdoses exploded all
of these Blue Chip companies have left
Portland Banana Republic Portland
because it was becoming a Banana
Republic you remember during that summer
when they laid Siege to the federal
courthouse they were shining laser beams
60 nights in these Asian size yeah for
60 straight nights throwing Molotov
cocktails they dropped all the charges
against these guys and then the next
summer they came in and they were street
fighting blasting commercial grade
fireworks at everybody he didn't do
anything about it and Trump said you
don't kind of help out a little bit and
he said take your hate elsewhere now all
of a sudden he's about to do something
no that's only because there's an
election and then there's mayor Adams
don't listen to music on the subway
don't pack heat on the subway but get
vaxxed
you know that Kobe
the crime crime's just in your hair it
remember the other Democrat politician
here that was like you know what if
there's an armed robbery in progress
spill a soda distract them they're in
now this is like the time in the crime
wave where we get safety tips from the
politicians
why is it our job to fight the crime
wave we've elected them to fight crime
if you're not going to fight it I need a
tax rebate so I can spend money on Jiu
Jitsu lessons or something because it's
their job Harold here in New York there
are many house races that might flip to
Republicans and part of the reason a
great reason is because crime is at the
top of this even beating inflation and
so you're looking at somebody like a
Democratic leader of Sean Patrick
Maloney who's the head of the D Triple C
who looks like he's going to be taken
out by Mike Lawler the Republican
candidate and it's like the Democrats
all of a sudden are talking about crime
they missed it
look I think whenever you have I don't
disagree with you Dana there are three
seats here in New York uh one or two
probably should be contested there's one
that there's a real surprise about uh
and crime is at the top of the list I'm
a different a little slightly here now
whenever there's a convert to my side I
agree with it and I just take them like
when they're people who used to root for
Ohio State and want to root for Michigan
we will take you on to our side and when
they're people who Republicans who
flipped on choice at the end of their
primaries I accepted them now is it
political perhaps but we have a problem
and I've tried to explain to my party
for a long time at least the last
several months we can't be for violent
criminals having cashless Bill we cannot
be for not fully funding the police I
will add there was a fully a bill that
went before Congress three weeks ago
that funded the police Republicans
didn't like all of it and all of them
voted against him Democrats ought to
point that out but the bigger issue
judging others is not lost I think on a
lot of Voters when you just like in our
last segment when you tell people that
inflation and the economy are the real
problem or that Biden should be
campaigning in a certain place people
aren't saying it some people aren't
feeling that Democrats who believe that
crime is not an issue and point the
statistics to try to suggest that there
have been a lot of people who've lost
races because they're trying to tell the
voter what you're feeling what you're
experiencing and how safe you are if
Kathy Holcomb wants to make a switch or
a shift or she's just amplifying a point
she has we should accept it because I
live in New York I take the subway I
don't take it as much and we need our
streets safer and our Subways safer and
anything and anybody that can help us do
that I accept should they've come sooner
judge without question but I embrace
them now as they come to our side I
agree with you I would embrace them too
if she said something that would make a
difference
other than I'm going to stop the crime
what are you going to do 1200 I agree
but she's come around over time she's
come around cast a spell you're the
governor make it happen I agree with a
huge number of retirements of the NYPD
and the recruiting is really tough hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else